what's the biggest uh area
of aspect of your philosophy they get
pushed back with which part of it
oh if there were no government monopoly
on police you would be
uh raped and murdered immediately and
what do you think about that
why don't i have a gun why can't i hire
a bodyguard
why can't i get a security system it's a
very bizarre
and if someone's coming to break in my
house right now
the cops aren't gonna do anything anyway
how am i getting to the phone so it's a
very
um weird scenario they construct because
the
the argument is apparently under an
anarchist system
all combat is one-on-one and weapons
don't exist
got it so for what you believe in you
you don't believe in defunding the
police you just believe we don't need
cops right
well we don't need a government monopoly
on cops you certainly need security
but in the same way that if the
government didn't produce clothing we
wouldn't all be naked
uh if you didn't have a monopoly and any
monopoly if you have a monopoly on a
product it's always going to be
delivered
inefficiently poorly and almost
inevitably at the cost of human life
whereas if you had choice and if you had
options
you would have innovation and you would
have solutions
instead of having a system where the
problems are perpetuated
uh for the sake of those in power so
if you have an anarchy you don't have a
government that has a monopoly
on cops right which means they control
that
but if you have an anarchy in an anarchy
what does the government look like how
limited is it or is it not
there's no there's no government that's
what anarchy is yeah
so if there's no government and
everybody is everybody is running under
give me an example of when that worked
effectively
anarchy when you returned a sweater to
the department store
when you returned the sweater to the
department store yes
you had a conflict neither of you is in
a position of authority over one another
and the conflict was resolved amicably
and peacefully in seconds
now if i'm involving the government and
there's a conflict i have to
pay a lawyer which is exorbitant going
to cost more than a surgeon
and the outcome will be uncertain but
we're certain of it's going to take a
very long time
so that is one difference between how
the market saw and freedom
solves for disputes as opposed to having
it go through the state i guess what i'm
asking is give me a country that had a
system of anarchy that did very well for
you know a handful of decades
first of all you're not going to have an
anarchist country by definition
second of all i can give you several
examples like medieval iceland and
medieval ireland which had it for a
thousand years far along with the
constitution
i don't think that's a valid question
for several reasons one is
just because it worked in iceland and
ireland doesn't mean it's going to work
in 2021
and just because it hasn't happened
anywhere previously doesn't mean it's
going to be working in 2021 either
one example of this is the internet
right before the internet if you sat
down and posited the internet
it would sound maybe if not crazy
certainly hard to wrap your head around
we would have no idea what websites
would look like but at the same time
this something ended up happening has
now become a universal faction of
human life so anarchism isn't a location
it's a relationship
and it simply means that one of the or
that none of the parties
claims authority or has authority over
one another
so every country on earth right now is
in a state of energy toward one another
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye